national city often talks about light
they say that everyone here is blighted
they have two thirds of the city under a
blanket and it's been like that for
almost 40 years take a look around you
people are Americans you're not light
well I think it's a shame with the
city's trying to do to our gym trying to
take it away from us a lot of people
have a lot of you know hopefully not
dreams when they come to the gym you
know to get through their everyday lives
and are you know it's a shame that the
cities are trying to take that away from
us you know that's that's where is my
home right there you know I started at
eight years old for them to take it away
so much pretty it's pretty tough would
say Virginia
following the rally the City Council
held a public hearing regarding their
redevelopment plans March and now we're
ready to move forward on some of the
remaining portions including chula vista
national city and of course never last
hearing that we had here what are the
kids before you and told you I was the
one that was tagging your places I was
the one that was breaking into your
homes and so forth but because of cya
see I changed my life you can bring in
an incredible beautiful condo tower with
lots of tax money but it's not going to
do the same amount of go that we're
doing just consider that have open minds
take a leap of faith okay just please
keep supporting us do the right thing
save our gym thank you very much when
it's all said and done your honor we're
not going to move we're going to stay
here we're going to stay
depression is being given out there that
we are trying to kick the kids out we
don't miss children anybody actually get
a lot of sympathy and you get cameras
when you do that and there's been I
think a lot of approach to go out there
and try to sensationalize this as if the
city was doing something bad to you and
I'm here to state for everyone right
here now that is a really a bad rap that
some memory organization trying to give
the city because we have worked
diligently we will continue to work
diligently to find a good location on
july seventeenth 2007 the national city
city council voted to move forward with
the plan to redevelop the city using
eminent domain we had a councilperson
last night who sort of spoke to eminent
domain being a tool in that he equated
it to being sort of like a police
officer's gun that best when never used
but needed in order to sort of keep the
peace the threat of eminent domain is
like having a gun put to your head when
you're negotiating the sale of your home
it's just not a negotiation at all
people just don't have a choice when
eminent domain is on the table our focus
has in the kids
we are not going to quit and we're not
going to let them down they know that we
are a family and this family will take
care of them they may not have a both
mother and father at home but we are
here for them we are their family for
reason TV I'm drew Carey
you
you